this is a production of cornell
university
yeah welcome everyone uh this is the
last week of the cornell turf show here
in uh 2022 our third season
episode 18 where we're wrapping up yeah
three years of this frank um which
started as a as a pandemic
sort of outlet has now turned into a
series and
our guest today talking golf turf it's
dr ben mcgraw of penn state um little
does ben know we don't actually want to
talk turf with him today we frank's
probably just gonna rub the yankees uh
record in in his uh face for 30 minutes
but we'll see if that happens it's over
it's over for the red sox oh it is it's
that time i i said that from day one
they made no moves in the off season so
he can he can get ready for football
then he'll be rooting for the patriots
in a couple you still got the celtics i
hate nba i actually grew up a lakers fan
because my dad loved the celtics so
i mean
i watched the most amount of nba
basketball i've watched in three decades
the other night which was about two
quarters
traveling i i noticed that traveling
is not a thing anymore i had to look it
up in 2018 they changed the rule that
you can have a gather step the other
step together nobody on the offense
was inside the three-point line so
people must be putting up outrageous
rebound numbers that's i mean it was
just like i had been transported to a
whole new world oh
the nerve with gosh
data and the nba forget it
he's our local daryl morley what's that
guy from the rockets oh mori well now
he's 76ers yeah yeah okay listen
i'm gonna go cause you guys keep talking
we're not gonna get anything done here
this morning so let me welcome everybody
uh to the to the slideshow here uh for
those of you watching uh the webinar
watching live always happy to have you
those on the podcast uh always
appreciate it yeah carl three week three
years in
and this is a great shot of odessa new
york native
uh russ myers shop operation there at
the pga championship in southern hills
russ has had an enormously storied
career i'll brag about him because he's
a local kid
like 15 minutes from where we currently
live
um you know was that a cobleskill grad
went to augusta national for a decade
was i think in line there and then went
to card sound for a while to southern
hills
and then a little joint called la
country club where we worked on a
redesign with kill hands there
and now he's back at southern hills um
probably you know the worst part of this
he had to give up his miami heat tickets
when he left card sound i think he had
laker tickets as well but he's really
doing it right look at that screen setup
he's got there for the volunteers so
should be a a great weekend to golf and
i i for one am sick of hearing about uh
phil mickelson and his ridiculousness
myself okay it's hot oh my god it's
gonna get hotter and the dogs are
feeling and i know all of us with dogs
the three of us have them um you know
you've got to take care of these guys
and gals in the heat
you do not want them out there without
water
of course most of them are probably
jumping in ponds anyway drinking as much
as they want so no worries there and
also just a note you know i saw this
tweeted the other day it's a project
that we worked on a little bit in a
couple of remote sites with some client
research
putting these mats down over sod and
letting them grow right through it has
been an excellent tool for the end of
cart paths
we've seen this work in a lot of places
i've seen it work in concert venues at
bethel woods i've done it there we've
done it on a park at brookfield place
next to the 911 memorial uh the mats
have worked in these narrow openings
there a really excellent uh hot tip
there carl as i pass it to you for your
la oh before i do
last week uh
i got to attend the defense of currently
now dr michael beckham and those of you
watching live or watching the video you
can see our former cornell guy doug
soldat his major professor to his right
way over to the other end paul koch the
renowned turf pathologist at uw madison
and there i am uh just you know holding
my own with all these wonderful
scientists where michael got to
defend his thesis and carl i think your
tip of the day gets into michael's work
very excited about this let's hear it
yeah so so it's not one of the sexier
things we talk about frank but but
documenting your use of resources on the
golf course is really important and
especially for the future with with
climate change with a very fluid sort of
regulation environment
um it's important to keep track of how
much water you use how much fertilizer
you use
and we've done a little bit with this in
our rit project we've developed a
template a drought management
nutrient management template and it's
real simple it's these four pages uh
it's a lot of uh question and answer
fill in the blank and a lot of times
when you hear drought management plan
you think of writing a whole 20-page
document having to kind of come up with
that yourself from scratch
we prompt you to put all this
information in you could fill it out it
takes maybe 20 minutes and that can
serve as your drought management or
nutrient management plan so you can hand
that off to your to your owners to
people who who are maybe in a regulatory
environment and say here here's my plan
and you can learn all the information
that way
one of the other reasons this is
important is is because of michael's
work so frankie just came from
uh his defense uh essentially what
michael's done is come up with a way
to figure out how much a golf course
should use based on the soils based on
where the golf course is that the turf
varieties how much water should they use
fertilizer energy right like carbon
emissions gasoline electricity uh
pesticide and he's found a way to
literally quantify all that and there's
a lot of equations and i was reading
through the thesis yesterday and it's
it's it's a minefield in there but the
bottom line is he's developing ways to
to figure out how efficient are we as a
golf course if i do x amount of rounds
and i use this much water is that
efficient is that good for my uh area of
the of the country is it bad
so michael has investigated this i'm
really excited to kind of dig into that
and figure out how we can maybe
get this data into superintendent's
hands and give them some information hey
in your area you should be using about
this yeah and that's where this
documentation of your resources comes
into play doing it for a couple years
here i know it's it's not a sexy thing
but
in in five years ten years maybe it's
going to be really valuable that you can
look back and and see how much you use
yeah no doubt carl and i gotta tell you
i put it into the category of
benchmarking
right i think one of the things we lack
sometimes in this business is you know
how am i doing compared to last year of
course we all pay attention to budget
and you know depending on where you are
maybe you measure actual water
uh but i think a lot of things don't get
benchmarked as much as they need to be
and i think this is what the the
quantifying generation that's coming
behind us uh guys like me ben you're
younger than me i'm the old guy
but i think this is going to come as
generations continue to advance
in this business and
pressures from regulatory and
environments and questions about usage
and you know what is going on improving
transparency
of the management out there so carl let
me get into the weather because we got a
bunch of insects to talk about with this
guy moving forward and some of it has to
do with the way we look at the weather
so you can see just as predicted really
hot uh to the north and inland a little
bit uh 12 degrees above normal in many
areas it certainly felt like that
throughout much of upstate new york uh
ben was not as warm as we were out there
in state college but as you got down to
the south you can see two degrees below
normal now still two degrees below
normal it was plenty warm and uh you can
see what this is doing now is it's
starting to level out the growing
seasons in
across the region you know the coastal
areas southern areas got going uh got
ahead a little bit and the northern
areas were falling behind and now we're
starting to see everybody starting to be
right around a week uh of normal uh some
even starting to creep ahead and we
would expect that to continue a little
bit over the weekend as we're expecting
a surge of heat uh over the weekend we
heard this morning as much as 20 degrees
above normal for a couple of days this
weekend and you look at the growing
degree day accumulation i mean we were
pressing to get 20 or 30 a week just two
weeks ago and now you're looking at 120
to 140 in the philadelphia area in
southern jersey and through where
rutgers is so things are going to get uh
hot uh really quick now that's of course
where we are now with soil temperatures
everybody looks pretty solid in the mid
to upper 50s depending on elevation and
and and well into the 60s and the heat
surge expected over the weekend is
certainly going to drive uh these
numbers up quite a bit rainfall wise
about everybody got about a half to an
inch region-wide but you look along the
cape uh and martha's vineyard the east
end of long island they were a little
bit behind uh they didn't get as much
rainfall out that end maybe closer to a
quarter inch or less of course further
north where they might have needed it
got quite a bit
up and way upstate in the adirondacks
northern vermont new hampshire
now the thing that's fascinating is you
start to see et vapo transpiration reach
into the inch and a quarter range in the
adirondacks uh in the finger lakes
region uh and you're certainly much less
in the metro new york area in the half
to three quarters of an inch so
depending on where you are uh
you know how much et how much rainfall
you got you look at where we were precip
minus et
and you can see a lot of people are
ahead of normal
the warmer spots the drier spots are out
western new york and along the new
england coast
inland rhode island connecticut
boston area really looking dry and and
really not looking for that much uh
improvement maybe a slight improvement
inland and along the coast maybe a
little bit half to one inch so enough
rainfall coming over the weekend uh to
keep things going which is perfect
timing for a growth surge but it also is
perfect timing as we start a
conversation about pest management and
you look at our forecast website
you see the you know the usual suspects
this time of may uh foliar anthracnose
style spot risk levels really high
starting to pick up certainly as the
rainfall comes and the heat comes so
this is risk in about three days from
now so we're looking at saturday sunday
risk uh across the weekend and the thing
that is a bit alarming is brown patch
which really needs much higher
temperatures to get triggered in
addition to the persistent leaf wetness
uh you really started to see it surging
uh into the metro new york philly uh
harrisburg area you got to watch out i'm
not sure i'd go out and spray
preventatively because he's certainly
going to grow pretty well but certainly
to the southern end of the region i'd be
a lot more concerned uh even about brown
patch something that we don't normally
consider now all i'd say is you couple
that with a growth surge and if you got
a lot of rye grass in particular uh that
will be really susceptible to brown
patch or a growth surge on older tall
fescues that might not have much brown
patch resistance i keep an eye out
for those things moving forward now just
add one more thing our forecast website
in addition to the daily risk we do a
lot of predicting and also looking back
so you can start to see now that over
the next several days you're moving into
a period of really high stress this is
the kind of models that we can look at
you know they give you context but
they're not always you know they're not
going to be exact it's going to give you
some ideas and i know ben has some
thoughts about this and there he is uh
i remember ben uh teaching my kid uh to
drive i believe this is is this your
daughter sadie
that is my daughter's seat it's so great
it's so great so at the research farm no
less though
okay all right so so but but there's so
many things to unpack here first off you
gotta love the look right she's just got
the look totally down here ben but more
importantly what is that thing on the
dash is that some star wars bobble head
you got there is that for good luck
that's vitruvius it's vitruvius from the
lego movie so
all right so listen let's get started um
you know you wrote a really nice blog
piece we're going to unpack it a little
bit in the green casting um and i'm
going to look at you here on the side
while we're doing this let's start with
this right we use this a lot you hear me
talking about this stuff you just heard
me right we're fully transparent about
this we've always used march 15th uh as
a start date because that's where back
20 years ago that's where a lot of the
models were starting to accumulate i
mean as we were getting them in turf
that's what they meant so let's start
there um what would you tell people what
kind of advice would you give people
about paying attention to growing degree
days when to start accumulating and how
to even get calculated
yeah that's a that's a really
interesting point so the the
blog post that you're talking about was
uh for syngenta weevil track yeah the
green cast place great yeah so
big shout out you know i'm not i'm not
selling chemical for syngenta but that
is exactly the kind of resource that i
think people should be using and i know
yeah
it's uh you know and we did a survey in
2017 and that that was the most popular
means of uh
scouting i get it's not really scouting
but uh
determining when you're gonna make your
applications for annual bluegrass wheels
so yeah definitely a big shout out
they've been doing it for a long time
since i was in grad school yeah uh
massive massive database
um if you think about it in those terms
you know over 14 15 years of data and
we don't have a unifying model for this
insect so that will tell you some of the
flaws with it as well
so you know
i have a pretty good understanding about
when populations are going to do certain
things because you know this is my
eighth field season here at penn state
which is hard to believe but um you know
we use a little monitor on site these uh
spectrum technology monitors they're not
great because they don't last very long
we have to replace them
frequently and it also leads to this
confusion that you know i think what
we're talking about here now is
that i have this number or i look on
weather.com and i see we're at 10 000
growing degree days and you're saying
we're at 400. you know what what's going
on so we're not really even speaking the
same language
um and with new technology coming on
board it's like
uh you know maybe it's time to strip it
down and and
eliminate it but you know we're just so
used to what do you think the average
guy is going to do can he can the
average person get away with
high and low divided by two
yeah i mean i think that's where we see
another i mean not only the device
that's been calculating that but how we
calculate it so what we use is the sine
curve basically the fluctuations
throughout the day rather than two data
points so okay um you know it's a little
bit more nuanced so already you can see
divergence right there okay um so the
average person's probably using like a
weather.com or um you know one of these
online services or i know michigan state
has a great one for yeah i believe yeah
they got g they got the gdp tracker
which we which we regularly refer to
here uh it sort of unifies things and
that we we get to talk about heat and
the development of insects so let's
start with we got a few things to do so
we're not going to kill this i got ants
i got worms i got crane flies we got a
lot of stuff to talk about yeah this of
course the big question
and you know you're so great about
tweeting stuff out for those of us that
you know i get out in the field too so i
have a little bit of a advantage but if
you're not out it's good to have this so
let's start with you know right now
where we are how did slow spring
development particularly up north here i
mean i think john hoyle at corning is
just treating
compared to what you call more tropical
populations let's start with how this is
all these slow things are helping
affecting moving reproducing egg laying
and application time yeah so insects are
cold blooded that's the simplest way
that i can put it so they're only going
to be as active as the temperature
allows
we saw a lot of warmth
uh prior to when we started calculating
growing degree days which for us is
march first
so you know there's some questions about
how did that affect them and then on the
early side in those first couple of
weeks
you know we might have accumulated 20
growing degree days base 50
um
in that two-week period so not a whole
lot but there was definitely some warm
period on the early side of tracking and
even before tracking and we entered this
cold uh kind of stretch where we didn't
see a whole lot of things and then we'd
get these bursts of like two or three
days of warmth and then uh you know i
don't remember frost like what we've had
this year so
uh in
really last week into this week
in earnest really
accumulating 100 growing degree days in
a in a weekly period is is pretty good
and and i would say we're going to
continue on in that trend
and then friday what happened what i
heard they marched out with that heat
you're talking about
and then they sort of stood there like
okay okay okay now what and i you know
olga was suggesting in one of her
writings that that might intensify
some of the feeding and the egg laying
it also might help you target an
application if they're all in one place
you can take more of them out at once is
that what you saw and are you worried
that that might be make the injury worse
because the feeding is so concentrated
yeah so i mean they physically fizzy
physically really can't move uh if it's
you know freezing temperatures they just
don't have the ability to move so um
that was our concern we saw a lot and
this was similar to last year we saw a
lot kind of hanging out in the border on
the rough side of fairways or callers
uh and maybe there's some micro
migrations going back and forth like
it's starting to get cold so they kind
of protect themselves somewhat
my thinking is that
based on what we saw for adult numbers
it's going to be a big year anyway
which means you know whatever happened
last year probably at the end of the
year allowed for bigger populations to
go in
uh i do think that you know the people
who
had a well-timed adulticide which is one
of the advantages of following weevil
track i think people really nailed it so
you know we do a lot of research on a
lot of courses and i also kind of
monitored uh different golf courses for
them and make their decisions for them
and i would say all of those courses
where you know if you follow the book
and buy the book you've done all right
to this point now i still have people
who i'm on their property
once a week and say
don't do anything until
i tell you to do and then you come back
last week and they're like man i just
got nervous and i put it down so i'm
seeing a lot of that especially with new
products well and and you know there's
two things there one is that's worrisome
right because you miss you go back and
now you you know that's the problem with
the pyrethroids right ben i mean we
applied in the connecticut guys were
applying five in the spring
years trying real hard not to swear on
this podcast
ivy league
podcast uh it's absolutely insane to me
in 2022 that
people had made
multiple pyrethrite applications prior
to adult peak i saw that in multiple
i mean and really where i'm at at this
point frank i've been in the lab since 4
30 this morning
i've got a
technician out with double pneumonia
i've got a kid with code right now the
whole world is just kicking me in the
teeth
and yet what i'm most frustrated is that
we're like regressing back to like
2008 with just like
i fear
it's fear it's fear it's the fear of the
unknown and we do have some new products
on the market that has created some
confusion even though i thought we were
pretty solid on how to use these
products but uh
yeah i'm i'm exhausted one from the road
travel there's not a day that goes by
that i'm not driving this is a rare day
where i'm in the office slash lab
uh but it's just it's kind of
frustrating right now that um you know
still see that now let me get off here
listen we we carl and i uh share that
frustration and we curse too on an ivy
league podcast
tell me about the uh
tell me about egg laying right because
this is about now the damage is going to
come from mom walking around with the
eggs that olga counts come in its gut
enter you know in the gut
uh they're gonna start laying them out
there
um
we've obviously started that
uh
a lot of the damage sometimes depends on
how long that period occurs
and then
number one does he
drive that egg lane
let's start with that
yeah so an egg laying driving it and
then we'll get to the pyrethroid
resistant larvicide activity yeah so one
thing going back to the start if we
think of you know and just arbitrarily
to start when we start
uh collecting adults what we did see is
we saw adults were out for a very long
period of time
however i think that egg lane was really
compressed so one temperature's kind of
fluctuating we see them at the edges and
my fear is that you're gonna have a
little bit more edge damage because of
that stopping and starting and then kind
of locking them in place so one it was
good if you timed your adult aside or
put out an adult aside i think you've
got a big chunk of the population
uh two
there there is a long period of time
between emergence from these
overwintering sites and when we see egg
deposition so i dissect them i look and
see if they're even
physically able to lay eggs
so that bodes well i think on many
accounts but then it kind of went
really really rapidly and so i think we
would see a lot of eggs being dropped
i've just evaluated a couple of trials
adult timing trials
and we're still seeing that spread you
know we've got between first and third
in stars right now
in all of our areas from columbus to
harrisburg okay do you like that for
timing
do i like that the spread out stages i'd
like to see it a little more consistent
but that that's pretty much a normal
distribution
i would say eastern pennsylvania to ohio
we're averaging you know it's right on
the cusp of the the true larvae side
timing window okay that's what i meant
do you like it for the timing that
spread
does that that makes it harder it would
seem to
get the right timing and then there's
this other thing that we talked about
with olga if you've got pyrethroid
resistant
populations those early stages may not
be as susceptible or you might need a
different chemistry can you talk a
little bit about that as we're
frustrated about too many pyrethroid
apps
yeah i mean definitely with too many
pyrethroid apps and resistance you'd
start to lose efficacy on on certain
larvicides not all larvicides
you know i think ference looks still
pretty good against resistant populated
matchpoint which is a spinosa product it
looks really good and soprato the new
one that you guys don't have in new york
uh also doesn't seem to be affected so
those are you know those are in my
opinion the top three larvicides that we
have available to us right now and and
the good thing is
they're less sensitive to that
other ones
uh we definitely see a decrease in
activity but really the main concern i
think with larvicides is time in it
relative to the nuances between the
larva sides if they don't have residual
activity and you're putting them out
when those larvae are first emerging
from the plant you've got a lot more
that are coming down the pipeline and
especially if you didn't control the
adults then you're going to just have
continuous egg laying well and i know
you worry about this right i remember i
had you on the other podcast
said you know that larger side only
thing is sexy but
you're going to get overwhelmed with
populations uh you know i'm assuming you
still feel that way that you have to
have an adult aside
incorporated with a program not just
rely on larvicide yes no i do and i i
don't think that i've
i'm going to preface all of this stuff
with i've seen every
insecticide fail everyone even though
we've got these new and sexy things that
have come out we've seen everything fail
in at least one trial if not
you know it's more than at least one
right
so
i do think that there it needs to be an
approach where you combine these things
and we're looking at different things in
our laboratory right now where
uh that seemed to enhance
adult
delta side applications or these new
products might have some interesting
adult activity as well so
um i think you can do it without
you know screwing your chances for
having larvicides work i think it's just
a smart way but you know any of the
courses that i consult with it's we're
doing one adult aside and it's in spring
that's it after that we're
solely in the larvicide approach so it's
not
that i believe that we should be
spraying out these organophosphates that
were developed in 1950 all year long
what i'm saying is we got one chance
where there's one stage present and we
can really tighten things up and make it
easier it's so great i mean that's such
an important message and gives me a a
good way to change to another insect in
the last few minutes ben yeah what's
with this uh ola racy thing um is this a
thing that's more of a novelty and some
guys have lots of problems that
eventually go away or is this something
that's going to be on the list of things
i got to worry about for the next 10
years yeah i mean this one is is kind of
a neat one i mean it's uh usually
co-occurs with the other one the the
european crane fly palladosa
i'm less concerned about this one
this one would be flying probably right
now in upstate new york probably towards
the tail end uh we have we see a long
emergence and flights of these guys uh
in
everywhere i've lived you know you get
great pictures too yeah so this this was
on mother's day um
my son and i were playing golf and then
i said perfect
i saw some father's day gift
yeah i i saw some guy on twitter say my
dad
and i when i was young i remember
driving by a golf course my dad said to
me only the [ __ ] and the divorce
play golf on mother's day so
i'm not divorced so you can figure out
which one i was but had i not been
playing had i not been playing frank i
would not have seen this mass emergency
and i think there's an argument for the
scientific value of you playing on
mother's day what about ant mounding
exploded overnight so what we saw was
seed heads uh poe annual seed heads
dandelion appeared overnight like boom
and then it's everywhere same thing with
the ant mounding last saturday we hadn't
seen anything which is pretty late i
mean it's uh you know so that probably
would have been about the 16th or the
14th somewhere in there that's pretty
late for us to see ant mounding
earthworm populations have been pretty
slow too
and i think we're going to kind of
skate through with that pest is that
it's going to get really hot here and
that's going to decrease casting but
ants i i suspect with this hot weather
is just going to explode out of the
ground what do you recommend should uh i
i know it's pretty in vogue to treat the
mounds but
i i've heard other people tell me it's
best to treat and try to find where the
farm is and treat the adults there
yeah i mean
ants are difficult to control in new
york because you don't have clothianidin
i really i mean and i'm not tied to any
company but uh you know like products
like aloft that have
bifenthrin uh you could make your own a
neonic
pyrethroid combination is kind of what
we see is the best in all of our trials
um some of our everywhere spray
everywhere or should you target where i
think you could band i mean that's what
we do in our trials and that will shut
down the mound that's a way that you can
reduce the amount of spraying but yeah
you know the pyrethroids if you're just
using pyrethroids and that's a common
thing they work very well and they shut
down the mound but in 7 to 14 days those
mounds are right back because all you've
done is killed the workers
when they don't come back to the colony
mom just starts making more and it takes
a little bit more time oh there's some
evidence that they can sense residues
and just avoid that for a couple what
about baits what about getting one of
those workers to take something back to
mom and yeah poison pill we don't have
good baits for uh ants in the north and
this is fire ants in the south and in
even indoxicard which we know as proven
you know that's an active ingredient
that does dynamite against fire ants
which are much harder to control than
these guys so
uh for the most part uh we think that
these ants sense staleness and baits and
they reject them so no kidding um you
know listen listen we're in the witching
hour and you said that uh the heat uh
might affect the williams
so i thought i'd give you uh a way to
wrap up our tenth season by talking
about worms uh because this is
something that could have destroyed the
golf business years ago uh if we didn't
get it under control and without the
supponens although we did hear wind
there might be another one on the market
uh this this is becoming a big problem
and i don't want to get into the jumping
worms let's just talk about about these
things on golf courses well i made these
jumping worms that are on golf courses
lesser extent more like mulch beds and
stuff
[Music]
worms have been pretty light here in a
few areas um you know we're looking at
different cultural practices to remove
them and most recently we start work on
electro shocking them out of the ground
which has been a real fun project with
some directed energy systems so
hopefully stay tuned on that um as far
as chemistries go you know there are no
legal means
uh even our saponin-based products
need multiple applications they're
rather expensive and companies have kind
of dropped them for either ethical
considerations or uh chinese tariffs
because they're byproducts of the tea
industry
uh so it has been challenging we've been
looking at you know you know what does
aeration do to these things can we
disguise this a little bit can we
vertical them
do different sorts of manipulations that
way as well
uh but yeah no insecticide or fungicide
that's gonna come out in in the next
five to ten years is likely to have any
sort of activity whatsoever so so the
answer is really on the cultural side
and carl let me pass it to you see if
there's questions but i'll let you
comment this came up in the walk and
talk and i believe steve curtis the
president of our gcseny
uh at tuscarora is uh doing something
innovating you want to take a minute and
talk about that
yeah well and actually john daniels is
with us as attendee today and john
visited steve and so steve's been
thinking for a couple years he's got
kind of ryegrass poet fairways and he
sees a ton of castings and he's actually
thinking about switching to bent grass
which which anecdotally around here and
i've seen it in bent grass patches you
don't see the casting but you see them
and and maybe the thinner less dense uh
lower organic matter grasses i don't
know if you've seen that ben but is that
an effect actually all of our earthworm
trowels are done on uh five-eighths inch
creeping been grass crenshaw so
um
there could be you know i mean
i i know the usga is pushing zoysia
grass really hard i don't see issues
there so i i kind of like where you're
going with it with maybe some of these
newer bent grasses maybe more aggressive
uh harder to get through but they they
do just fine here um in our bent grass i
do think we do see them on rye grass and
whether that's
um you know lower budgets less chemicals
going out on those types of fairways or
whether it's a bunch type so it allows
them to come to the surface
uh it's just a really hard thing um
hopefully we're making a few strides
here but every two steps forward we take
a couple back
and we've just taken a real couple back
uh where we were doing trials
on our bent grass plots here that have
some pretty severe casting had a massive
rainfall
and
what came out of the ground is a new
asian invasive so
not the jumping worm but a green stink
worm that dan potter's worked on for
many years
um these things are kind of grayish
black looking if you pick them up
they'll secrete a yellow fluid
that has a stench to them
um
it's likely that it wasn't bad enough
yeah it's likely that these are going to
start casting during the summer so if
you do see casting within interiors and
these are native soils but modified over
the years with sand top dressing
and you know potter saw it where they
were constructing new uh tee boxes where
they brought dredge material from the
ohio river so uh something to look out
for if you do see casting at a time when
we shouldn't be seen casting yeah listen
carl we're way past but maybe we want to
take a question i'll just make a comment
we move soil around this country
willy-nilly
yeah and i i've watched this with with
the uh crane fly with a lot of the
problems that uh dan peck and then kyle
picked up on uh moving a lot of these
organisms with soil
uh the worms moving with soil that's a
big problem carl ben before before i
take any questions thanks for joining us
and i hope life doesn't keep kicking you
in the ass there's a yeah i didn't know
this was going to be on video so i'm i'm
looking a little ha i thought there was
a radio production at least i put on a
shirt yeah i know that's better go ahead
carl questions
yeah just one question from blake we'll
get you out here quick then uh he's
heard you say in the past that uh you
like provon and ference for second
generation adults
uh with there's been off the market uh
there's a lot of resistance pyrethroids
what do you suggest for the first spring
in delta side
uh so the overwintering uh adult aside
um you know believe it or not there's
still people who do pretty well with
pyrethroids
um
those that don't
uh have the option for pyrethroids that
puts us in a very small category
of either chlorpyrifos which we're about
to lose uh and that seems to do really
well you know people are using it for
probably the last time here in
pennsylvania and still i think new york
is done
yeah i think new york is gone acifeed is
another organophosphate that could be
used um
man it's got a terrible stink about it
but uh you know talking to
our rod ferentino the other day when we
do our weekly roundup uh
you know he he got a pretty good whack
with it so there's a couple of um acifie
products out there man uh the stink is
unreal though
at the high rate of course yeah
absolutely high rate i think he was
complaining that somebody didn't use the
high rate
and got less than optimal control so
yeah those are your options we've been
doing a lot of projects uh i have a
student working on resistance and
characterizing microbiomes of resistant
populations
uh and we started to look at
incorporating surfactants with our
pyrethroids and really just screening
different chemistries different classes
of surfactants and really seeing some
really interesting synergies um and some
papers have come out i've seen the exact
same thing on bed bugs so i think that's
a rabbit hole that we're going to go
down for the next well surfactants that
encourage the spreading across the
exoskeleton right are going to help uh
in a lot of different ways so listen we
got to be good this is 10 years uh 10
weeks and three years of 10 weeks ben
and with this is the longest we've ever
gone over oh man so it's so good to see
you it's great to see you guys my
sympathies for a really uh lousy red sox
season i'll let you know how it goes nah
i'm feeling the pain i'm feeling pain
all right carl
thanks everyone for uh for joining
episode 18 of the cornell turf show
we'll hope for a couple wins for uh
ben's red sox not too many just a couple
maybe help him feel better
guys we'll see you guys next uh tomorrow
for the last sports show take care this
has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu